bonjour et bienvenue pour un nouveau
live aujourd'hui on va vous parler d'un
sujet qui provoque forcément des
fantasmes c'est celui des ovnis des
ovnis et puisque la NASA très sérieuse
NASA a tenu une conférence de presse de
plus de 4 heures mercredi pour parler de
ce sujet et on va débriefer tout ça on
va en parler avec Cyril Vandenberg
bonjour Cyril merci avec nous rédacteur
en chef au service sciences je le
rappelle vous n'étiez pas tout au soleil
à poser vos questions on y répond au
mieux comme d'habitude on va découvrir
un peu ces petites images et sur sur ce
que sur ce qu'on a appris sur les ovnis
est-ce qu'on savait déjà
on va montrer ces images là c'est ces
images de cette réunion publique comme
la NASA qui a duré 4 heures donc la NASA
s'intéresse aux ovnis oui ça c'est en
fait c'est ça la vraie nouveauté c'est
on va on va casser le suspense il y a
pas eu de révélation fracassante
ni sur l'absence de d'OVNI sur les
explications où ça représente
l'extraterrestre c'est pas ça c'est pas
ça le sujet par l'actualité c'est
vraiment que l'agence spatiale
américaine s'empare du sujet avec un
avec pas mal de sérieux et donc à
présenter cette semaine ça première
audition publique sur le sujet avec un
panel on a vu il y avait il y avait du
monde derrière le
la table de panéhélice là c'est 16
experts qui ont été choisis par la NASA
il y a des astrophysiciens des
physiciens des métiers relangistes à des
astronautes des pilotes de ligne des
gens de compétences assez variés pour
essayer de faire le point sur ce qu'on
connaît sur ces phénomènes inexpliqués
les ovnis alors peut-être revenir sur le
le point de départ
déjà
c'est c'est un ovni c'est quelque chose
c'est un objet volant non identifié si
je le trouve pas oui et voilà exactement
donc ça cette définition là elle est
ancienne et
même si aux États-Unis le terme le terme
utilisé par la NASA n'est plus celui de
UFO
objet volant non identifié qui vendent
français et on parle maintenant de UAP
phénomène aérospatial inexpliqué en
français on dit pan
donc une nouvelle terminologie qui
rentre peut-être aussi le sujet un peu
plus acceptable pour le grand public et
pour les politiques mais au-delà de ça
c'est qu'il y a c'est le symbole d'une
véritable un changement
de prise en compte du sujet à Washington
donc parce que en fait il y a une vraie
attente du public on a on a dans
l'imagerie populaire on a on associe les
ovnis aux extraterrestres ces vieux
comme X-Files les plus jeunes comme
comme vous connaissez pas forcément mais
voilà effectivement et voilà donc c'est
dans cette imagerie populaire OVNI c'est
forcément extraterrestre et en fait il y
a un vrai sujet à essayer de comprendre
des observations qui sont faites qui
sont nombreuses qui sont parfois
vraiment troublantes et sur lequel on
n'a pas d'explication donc il y a on
peut avoir une démarche scientifique sur
le sujet en se disant
des personnes que crédibles comme des
pilotes de ligne par exemple observe des
phénomènes ils sont vraiment hors du
commun qu'on n'arrive pas à expliquer de
manière évidente est-ce qu'on dit bah
ils inventent ils ont délire c'est
l'alcool les drogues je n'en sais rien
ou alors on prend le sujet sérieux et
c'est ce que fait aujourd'hui la NASA
avec un panel de scientifiques des gens
de qualité qui ont
l'air de pas avoir d'apriori sur le
sujet c'est pas des c'est pas ni des
fanas parce qu'il y a deux camps cette
thématique qui sont deux grands qui
s'affrontent c'est à côté les
ufologues donc les ceux qui pensent que
ce que les ovnis sont des signes de
présence extraterrestres de
l'intelligence qui viennent nous visiter
sur terre
ils sont dans un camp qui qui
sont assez ils sont en réseau sur
internet ils se parlent ils se
communiquent
il y a eu des sociétésologues
ufologues aux États-Unis depuis les
années 70 donc ça fait même qui est pas
nouveau mais qui perdure et de l'autre
côté il y a des rationalistes
des gens qui sont des scientifiques qui
disent mais non mais ça c'est
pas d'extraterrestres d'ailleurs ces
phénomènes c'est des illusions optiques
des voilà des gens qui s'inventent des
choses et donc en fait il y a une
position entre les deux qui est de dire
ben il y a quand même des gens crédibles
des gens qui m'ont dit notamment il y a
pas mal de il y a des dizaines de
témoignages de pilotes de ligne ou des
pilotes de chasse il voit des choses il
voit des choses dans le dans leur
pratique dans leur métier au quotidien
et qui savent pas l'expliquer et donc on
a aussi des enregistrements on a des
images alors ces images là par exemple
alors c'est souvent les images qui ont
été montrées cette fois-ci c'était des
images plus vieilles par exemple et
c'est des pilotes de la de la de la
Royal Navy
de l'US Navy qui ont filmé ces images et
qui ont dit tiens il y a quelque chose
de bizarre sur ces images alors ça c'est
en fait ces images là c'est trois il y a
trois vidéos qui ont des noms des noms
qui avaient été déclassifiés en 2020 par
le Département américain de la Défense
elles sont très intéressantes parce que
ce sont des documents qui sont
certifié c'est-à-dire qu'ils sont
enregistrés par des enregistrements de
vol avec des capteurs infrarouges par
des avions de chasse c'est l'usscville
donc c'est pas des rigolos les images
sont vraiment troublantes elles sont
étonnantes quand on n'a pas
d'explication on est vraiment sans tête
de se dire quelque chose d'inexpliquées
quelque chose de fantastique elles sont
alors elles sont en souvent en
infrarouge donc les sources chaudes
apparaissent de manière l'une plus
lumineuse plus claire là comme ça sur
fond noir sur cette image là où on
optique avec des forces zooms des effets
de zoo de grossissement aussi qui qui
changent un peu notre perception de ces
images on n'a pas de repère extérieur
et on est enfin elles sont difficiles
interpréter parce que c'est des images
assez techniques qui sont destinées on
ces capteurs là à soit
identifier des appareils ennemis à la
longue distance ou des cibles au sol
pareil à longue distance donc on est
dans l'outil militaire on n'est pas dans
un bruit de cinéma pour faire joli et
c'est avec quoi on filme ces choses là
et c'est ça qui rend le qui rend le
phénomène observé encore plus
impressionnant et alors et là où là où
en fait je rapproche ces vidéos qui ont
été les classifiées en 2020 avec le
mouvement que que et la conférence de la
NASA et cette semaine c'est qu'il y a à
Washington plusieurs politiques des
hommes politiques qui demandent à ce que
l'État fasse la lumière sur le phénomène
donc c'est en fait une réponse au
complotistes qui disent voilà le
gouvernement allait à des données il
nous cachent la vérité ils ont les
preuves de présence d'extraterrestres
ils ont des matériaux secrets qui leur
permet de faire des avions secrets
toutes les variétés du complot elles
sont larges elles sont riches et l'idée
c'est derrière pour expliquer
rationnellement pourquoi est-ce qu'on
voit ces images là donc voilà donc il y
a une pression politique à Washington de
gens qui ont pas honte de parler du
sujet et qui disent ben gouvernement
mais dites-nous ce que vous avez sur le
sujet et donc le mouvement
qui a une commission de département de
la Défense qui a été nommé pour
étudier le sujet sous supervision
parlementaire américaine et là donc
cette commission scientifique de la NASA
c'est c'est aussi l'expression de cette
volonté politique elle a été
c'est une commission qui a été nommée à
la demande express du nouveau patron de
la NASA bilnelsson est un gars assez
extraordinaire qui est un ancien
astronaute là c'est âgé qui a été
sénateur démocrate pendant des années et
qui est un peu un gars un peu
[Musique]
cowboyant la vérité sur le sujet les
Américains ont envie de savoir allons-y
aux Américains les Américains veulent
savoir et on va organiser une conférence
comme vous voyez sur ces images et on va
expliquer en fait finalement d'où
viennent ces phénomènes alors on arrive
à expliquer dans le meilleur des cas et
en fait ce que ce qu'on dit ce qu'on dit
ce qu'on rapportait les experts ils ont
ils ont dit quelques il y a eu quelques
éléments intéressants quand même il y a
pas eu de révélations fracassante mais
il y a eu des éléments intéressants
d'une part
c'est qui sentait qu'il y avait une
pression très forte de l'opinion et de
certaines personnes sur les réseaux
sociaux sur les sur les membres du panel
donc des gens qui leur disaient mais
c'est ce que vous faites c'est quand
idiot arrêtez de perdre votre temps et
l'argent du contribu avec ses conneries
ou alors vous êtes devant le composé
vous êtes instrumentalisé par le pouvoir
et vous nous cachez la vérité donc il y
a une fonction qui a une pression la
première chose qu'a dit le responsable
de la NASA qui a ouvert l'audition c'est
de dire on a besoin de sérénité pour
faire un travail scientifique de qualité
et les pressions qui ressentent certains
membres du panel sont vraiment très très
lourds des parfois limite du harcèlement
donc
un contexte qui est assez lourd quand
même qui va être compliqué pour
travailler dans ces conditions
l'autre chose qui était intéressante
c'est qu'ils ont dit que sur les
centaines de cas déclarés qu'ils ont
dans leur dossier
il y en avait qu'une toute petite
minorité qui n'avait pas d'explication
ça c'est intéressant c'est qu'on parle
de 2 à 3%
bah ça veut dire qu'il reste quand même
des cas inexpliqués des cas qui méritent
d'être étudiés avec avec attention
voilà enfin
les officiellement le les images qu'on a
vu l'un des images de l'US Navy elles
ont pas été expliquées officiellement
par
le moment par ce panel mais
il y a sur Youtube quelques chaînes
américaines qui font des explications
assez convaincantes
pour dire ben voilà on a des
explications assez simples pour
expliquer ces phénomènes qui nous
paraissent troublants et totalement
impossible
moyen technique qu'on connaît
aujourd'hui et qui en fait peuvent être
des effets d'optique
là on voit une vidéo en ce moment c'est
l'une des vidéos qui a été présentée
c'est un c'est un avion enfin c'est un
avion c'est une boule lumineuse qui fait
des allers-retours en bas à droite de
l'écran alors si on le voit maintenant
mais qui fait des allers-retours à
droite de l'écran ils ont dit
effectivement c'est comme vous voyez en
haut il y a marqué donc c'est résolu
c'est une illusion d'optique parfois et
voilà mais et
en fait la difficulté c'est de
pas mal de ces observations c'est qu'il
y a des capteurs qui sont mobiles donc
qui se déplace à haute vitesse regarde
un autre objet
qui lui aussi peut être mobile
et en fait il y a une des vidéos qui est
je sais pas si on peut la voir c'est
celle de du GoFast où on voit un objet
qui vole à l'impression qu'ils veulent
très très haute vitesse au-dessus des
au-dessus des flots
qu'ils ont montrées
ville en
celle-là mais belle
et en fait l'explication la plus simple
c'est qu'on voit cet objet qui est assez
brillant on a l'impression qu'ils vole à
une vitesse mais phénoménale aura des
flots aura des vagues et en fait il faut
il faut alors je fais je fais les gestes
avec les mains mais
l'idée c'est que l'avion ils veulent la
haute altitude il regarde un objet qui
est plus bas que lui
et il le il le voit sur le fond de de
l'océan donc comme lui la vitesse de
l'avion est assez élevée il y a un effet
de ciseaux qui fait que le fond de
l'océan se défie la toute vitesse et en
fait l'effet de la de la vitesse de
l'avion mais la vitesse la perception
qu'on a de la vitesse de l'objet
au-dessus de l'eau les pièces de l'avion
en fait et en fait c'est surtout la
vitesse de l'avion qui est très élevée
donc on a c'est un optique c'est un
effet de parallaxe et un effet de lune
de visée qui se qui se décale et ça
c'est les choses qui sont avec un schéma
et des flèches et des on comprend on
comprend assez facilement ce qui se
passe donc
voilà on arrive là c'est exactement
l'image est à l'écran là on voit le
l'objet au centre l'avion est à 25000
pieds est indiqué en bas il va à
Max 061 donc il va
être heureux et 25000 pieds je crois que
c'est 7000 ou 8000 mètres d'altitude ils
vont un objet qui en fait qui est plus
bas que lui et
qui avance sur les flots il avance pas
forcément si un ballon météo par exemple
qui redescendu après son observation et
qui est à peu près statique ou qui vole
voter par les vents la vitesse de
l'avion dans un sens opposé va donner
l'impression que lui se déplace que le
balance des places très haute vitesse
aura des flots d'accord donc c'est comme
ça qu'on peut effectivement expliquer
ces phénomènes qui sont les outils tout
à l'heure toujours une grande source de
questionnements des qui et qui sont et
qui sont observés et qui sont observés
depuis finalement alors c'est rendu
public maintenant mais c'est observé
depuis un moment même en France alors en
fait
la France la oui en fait les histoires
des ovnis elles sont elles sont vraiment
anciennes enfin tout le monde connaît
l'histoire de Roswell
1947 un objet qui tombe dans le désert
et en fait et en fait le Roswell c'est
pas le début
c'est l'histoire c'est marrante mais
c'est une reconstruction postériori
d'une histoire ancienne qui était
oubliée qui était quand on a parlé dans
les médias donc dans les 40
mais le vrai le vrai premier observation
d'une soucoupe volante qu'elle c'est
aussi 1945 c'est un pilote privé dans un
petit avion
qui vole près du Mont Washington dans le
nord des États-Unis et qui vont un objet
inexpliquer et c'est c'est le début du
phénomène soucoupe volant dans les
années fin des années 40
années 70 il y a une étape importante
par la France avec la création d'un
bureau au CNES donc l'agence spatiale
française création d'un bureau qui
s'appelle le GEPAN pour étudier on
appelle pas on parle pas d'OVNI on va
parler d'extraterrestre on va pas parler
de machin on parle de phénomène
aerospaccio
c'est ce qu'on disait au début on
abandonne petit à petit le théâtre de
l'intérieur
elle fait pas sérieuse donc on utilise
en français p panpan
UAP en anglais maintenant
donc il y a eu un bureau du CNES qui
était une petite équipe à Toulouse avec
je crois assez peu de moyens quand même
pour être honnête mais qui était chargé
de regarder quels étaient les
témoignages en France quels étaient les
observations donc à l'époque c'était des
photos quelques vidéos mauvaise qualité
à l'époque et d'essayer de trouver des
explications et donc ce bureau français
il existe toujours et c'est le premier
au monde chargé d'une démarche
scientifique
de manière institutionnelle pour
expliquer ces phénomènes donc c'était
donc la France avait de ce côté là avec
50 ans d'avance sur le NASA elle s'y met
mais le CNES
qui sont déjà dans le coup on va dire du
coup la NASA et on les font lisait c'est
aussi surtout pour reprendre dire le
contrôle sur le débat contraire c'est
c'est théorique alors je sais pas si
c'est contre les théories complotistes
mais c'est mais c'est aborder le sujet
avec une avec une humilité scientifique
de se dire c'est pas parce qu'on n'a pas
d'explication qu'il y a pas quelque
chose oui et après le
les objectifs de l'exploration de la
NASA dans le système solaire c'est la
recherche de la vie
et donc on peut difficilement dire et
bien on met des milliards pour
rechercher la vie sur Mars une planète
qui est désolé et qui a l'air vraiment
sèche et très très inhospitalière et on
regarde pas ce qui se passe chez nous
avec des phénomènes qui ont l'air
inexplicables et qu'on peut peut-être
attribuer vous êtes réussis à expliquer
si on si on se pose la question donc
honnêtement si on est si on est
scientifique honnête on doit se dire
mais oui il y a quelque chose qui n'est
pas expliqué ayant le courage de
l'affronter et de le regarder de manière
objective et d'essayer de de comprendre
ce qui se passe
et quelque part parce que si on trouve
c'est toujours la même chose si on
trouve la preuve d'une intelligence
extraterrestre c'est quand même la plus
grande découverte de l'histoire
l'humanité enfin c'est c'est
c'était raconté dans des centaines de
films de science-fiction mais c'est on
est on est quand même sur une question
qui est profondément enfin qui est
profonde est-ce qu'on est seul dans
l'univers est-ce que il y a de la vie
ailleurs est-ce qu'il y a de la vie
intelligente ailleurs oui et puis c'est
des questions que les gens que les gens
se posent et que et que les
scientifiques se posent j'ai découvert
en soleil ce qu'on appelle l'équation de
Drake oui qui explique que c'est
possible de savoir si oui ou non il y a
de la format extraterrestre c'est ça
alors les poissons c'est pas de savoir
mais en fait c'est une équation qui te
permet de déterminer les probabilités
d'existence
une civilisation extraterrestre dans
l'univers donc c'est ça veut pas dire
est-ce qu'il y a des ovnis qui visitent
la terre voir ce qu'on fait
voilà mais c'est c'est l'idée que quand
on regarde l'univers on sait que en
moyenne il y a
une planète autour de chaque étoile dans
l'univers dans le dans le dans le Galaxy
qui nous entoure donc si on extrapole ça
à la taille de l'univers on peut qu'on
peut faire une estimation de la du
nombre d'étoiles donc du nombre de
planètes
donc on a si on a planète on a on peut
regarder quelles sont les probabilités
d'apparition de la vie donc il faut que
la planète elle soit dans une zone qu'on
appelle une zone habitable autour de son
étoile ni trop chaude ni trop froid pour
qu'il puisse avoir de l'eau liquide donc
là on fait des hypothèses qui sont quand
même très très réductrices on dit que la
vie est en imagine la vie telle que la
connaissent c'est la nôtre donc c'est la
vie qui apparaît liée à la l'eau du
logis est liée à la présence d'eau donc
en fait ce genre d'hypothèse sur nombre
d'étoiles nombre de planètes probabilité
d'apparition de de la planète soit dans
une zone habitable
probabilité ensuite la vie apparaisse
alors là ça permet sur le canal n'a
aucune idée hein on est entre entre 0 et
0 % et 100% on a on a aucune idée on a
qu'un seul pendant l'observation sur la
terre
donc là on a un paramètre qui est un peu
une grosse inconnue et quand on fait
toutes ces calculs de probabilité et
bien on arrive à une estimation de la
chance qui est ou non une civilisation
extraterrestre dans l'univers qu'est-ce
que ça veut et en fait on arrive à
qui qui est spécial parce qu'en fait en
plus le facteur change énormément je le
ce sont les chiffres
mais en fait c'est c'est moi j'aime
beaucoup cette idée là c'est que c'est
quand même un sujet sur lequel on peut
avoir
un raisonnement scientifique et une
approche
voilà enfin une approche qui est
d'essayer de restreindre les Inconnus
qu'on a sur le sujet en fait c'est
passionnant et après on évite la
question de la vie la vie dans l'univers
elle est elle est sincèrement elle est
vraiment passionnante enfin les
recherches en cours pour comprendre
comment la vie est apparue sur terre
déjà elles sont loin d'être résolues on
a on n'a pas d'explication très claire
très très convaincante sur le passage
chimie on a des éléments d'une chimie ce
qu'on appelle prébiotique donc avec des
éléments assez plus ou moins complexes
avec des chaînes de carbone comment on
passe de cette chimie là à
même un ordinateur organisme le plus
basique connu c'est déjà d'une
complexité c'est qui qui est finalement
il y a un spécialiste du sujet qui me
disait c'est on a les on a les briques
et on voit la cathédrale la cathédrale
c'est le microbe le plus simple possible
et on sait pas comment on passe de la
brique à la cathédrale d'accord donc
effectivement
on a encore du boulot
et ça c'est sur le le domaine qu'on
connaît c'est la terre donc les autres
zones hors de la terre mais on a encore
moins d'infos et on cherche on sait rien
voilà alors c'est vraiment parce qu'on
parlait tout à l'heure de de différentes
façons de de traiter ce sujet la façon
très sérieuse et la façon on perd notre
temps justement dans les commentaires on
a et les morceaux sans casque il dit
merci pour ça je vous félicite d'aborder
ce phénomène qui est bel et bien réel et
de l'autre côté nous avons un intérêt
qui lui dit que tous les niveau des
formes circulaires passer devant chez
lui et il s'agit des assiettes de son
voisin donc voilà ça vous montre aussi
que c'est ces sujets là ça polarise
énormément même en France oui oui oui il
y a pas de réseau il y a pas de raison
[Musique]
moi je trouve que le sujet est fascinant
honnêtement
et on aurait on aurait vraiment tort de
passer intéressé
après on est on a quand même une
je trouve on est dans une dans une
période assez incroyable
où on a on a tous en poche un appareil
photo et un enregistreur vidéo avec nos
smartphones et pourtant depuis une
quinzaine d'années
on a plus
ou pas l'observation de gens qui voient
des ovnis à part les quelques rapportés
par la NASA ou l'US Air Force donc on a
on a à la fois les multiplications des
capteurs
et une très très peu de témoignages de
personnes et pourtant on a vraiment des
photos on en fait plein enfin et
les en fait là où j'exagère en fait on a
on a pas mal d'enregistrement et de
photos de nuit de phénomènes qui sont de
phénomènes spatiaux donc des entrées de
satellites des chutes de météorites il y
en a dit on a une multiplication des
images qui témoignent de ces phénomènes
aérospatiaux mais qui sont bien
expliqués et les Femen expliqués et
comme les soucoupes volantes dans les
années 80 ou la mode de ces trucs là il
y avait quand même pas mal de fake pas
mal de photos qui étaient des montages
mais est-ce que justement c'est parce
que maintenant on a on a l'opportunité
de de mieux vérifier et donc forcément
on a entre guillemets crée-moi
et ben
quelque part dans les années 80 les
années 70 la faiblesse des appareils
enfin les appareils photos étaient des
pellicules donc les photos qu'on pouvait
faire des objets mobiles dans le ciel
si l'objet était flou mais on se disait
bah c'est normal l'appareil photo
c'était loin le zoom était élevé donc on
ça s'explique une photo aujourd'hui une
photo floue avec des capteurs qui sont
incroyablement précis des autofocus
enfin ce que je veux dire c'est que
c'est moins acceptable d'avoir une photo
d'une soucoupe flou sur un fond gris il
non identifié on se dit bah oui c'est
Photoshop enfin c'est on a on a quelque
part on a perdu cette crédulité sur une
image flou qui est qui peut être un
montage enfin ce que je veux dire c'est
pas si je suis clair sur
l'explication c'est que les progrès
techniques dans la prise d'image font
que à la fois on en a plus mais qu'il
est il est aussi plus facile de de dire
bah oui c'est Photoshop ou c'est
un montage
là vous avez l'image aussi qui a été
montré on voit ce petit de développement
latéral là des points lumineux c'est
résolu c'est absolument pas anormal ça
peut s'expliquer scientifiquement voilà
si vous voulez retrouver d'ailleurs
cette conférence de presse on prévient
elle dure 4 heures sur le site de la
NASA merci beaucoup Cyril d'avoir été
avec vous merci à vous d'avoir été
nombreux à nous suivre on vous dit à
bientôt pour de nouveaux live sur
figuerolive
merci à vous de m'avoir été nombreux à
nous suivre je vous dis à bientôt pour
de nouveaux live sur client live